in the Rolling Hills of Ohio for 2 000
years a series of Earthen Mounds crafted
into precise shapes have lined the
landscape the Hopewell ceremonial
Earthworks are the lingering vestiges of
the Hopewell culture now being
considered as a UNESCO world heritage
site these aren't the walls of cities or
fortifications they enclose ceremonial
places
also the astronomical alignments in the
context of indigenous civilizations
those relate to aligning the Earthworks
with the cosmos
nestled among the midwestern trees and
fauna are a series of geometric shapes
the great circle and octagon in Newark
the massive square at Mound City
and the scattered forms of Fort ancient
the entrance to the circle and octagon
at the Newark Earthworks points to a
spot on the horizon where the Moon Rises
at its northernmost point every 18.6
years
they might not be as high as the
pyramids or as famous as Stonehenge but
archaeologists and historians believe
because of their geometric Precision the
astronomical knowledge it took to make
them and their massive scale the
Hopewell Earthworks deserve equal
recognition
most of the sites have been preserved
but Modern Life Is Risen around them
with roadways through ancient
embankments and a golf course soon to be
closed to preserve the historic site
where weekend hackers roll golf carts
over sacred Mounds
Brett Ruby an archaeologist for the
National Park Service says the
Earthworks were a Gathering Place for
Native Americans from all across North
America if you were here two thousand
years ago this would have been a
multilingual multi-ethnic place a very
Cosmopolitan place with different
languages and many different peoples
gathered here for ceremony
conservationists say Global recognition
will lead to better appreciation by
Travelers and that will lead to Greater
funding and preservation of a
prehistoric landscape surrounded by the
modern world John hendren Al Jazeera
Newark Ohio
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera